for every actor who revert back to their
usual self the second they hear the word
cut there's another who stays in
character for the entire duration of a
film's production of course living in
character around-the-clock can lead to
some pretty unusual situations as proven
by these hilarious things actors did
while in character Wesley Snipes left
post-it notes as blade blade Trinity
director David s Goyer and star Wesley
Snipes had an infamous onset battle over
Snipes refusal to take direction as a
leather-wearing vampire hunting ninja
the whole thing culminated in an
argument that turned physical when
Snipes attempted to throttle Goyer with
his bare hands from that point on
Snipes refused to speak to Goyer for the
rest of the shoot according to co-star
Patton Oswalt Snipes communicated solely
with the director via post-it notes as
an added bonus they were allegedly all
written in character each signed from
blade Leonard Nimoy Grox Spock because
of his high intelligence the Star Trek
character Spock was extraordinarily
popular with career academics and
scientists many of whom saw the
character as appear as a result Spock
actor Leonard Nimoy was often invited to
sit in on lectures and even look over
theses and research proposals by fans
who assumed he had a similar knowledge
of the fields of science to spare the
feelings of people who couldn't tell the
difference between an actor and a
pointy-eared alien from the future Nimoy
would affect Spock's mannerisms and tell
people well it certainly looks like
you're headed in the right direction
regardless of whether he actually
understood anything they'd said
fascinating Robert Downey jr. Method Man
in Tropic Thunder Robert Downey jr. is
Kirk Lazarus is supposedly one of the
world's most gifted method actors and so
committed to his craft that he undergoes
surgery to change the pigmentation of
his skin in order to appear black while
portraying his character Lincoln Osiris
fittingly Downey stating character as of
cyrus throughout the DVD commentary for
the film meaning he talked about the
movie as a fictional character being
played by another fictional character to
sum it up those who listen to the track
will hear Downey pretending to be an
Australian guy pretending to be a black
guy talking about a film within a film
[Music]
what Danny don't do everyone who's seen
machete knows one thing for sure
lunch at the don't take what you
probably didn't know is that this line
came about because star Danny Trejo also
doesn't text instead he tried to call
director Robert Rodriguez multiple times
to discuss some ideas about machetes
character Rodriguez finally called back
and asked why on earth Trejo didn't just
text him trails response was to get in
character and growl the since
immortalized line Rodriguez laughed so
hard he ended up putting it in the film
Liam Neeson has a particular set of
skills Bryan Mills Liam Neeson's
character from the taken franchise can
end a human life with nothing more than
a pinpoint-accurate slap to the throat
in other words he's a pretty scary guy
but what I do have are a very particular
set of skills skills I have acquired
over a very long career skills that make
me a nightmare for people like you so
imagine how terrified an unnamed
ex-boyfriend of Maggie Grace who please
Mills daughter throughout the series
must have been when Neeson in character
his Mills called him up to threaten to
punch his arms off as a joke of course
haha Adam driver does not need a hug
according to pretty much everyone
involved the production of Star Wars The
Force awakens Adam drivers spent almost
all of his time on the set in character
as the sullen kylo Ren he was so emo his
co-stars felt compelled to try to cheer
him up Mark Hamill for instance offered
to take driver to lunch and repeatedly
asked the young actor if he'd like to
hang out not wanting to break character
driver turned him down John boyega on
the other hand took a more direct
approach randomly hugging driver without
warning and full costume throughout
production according to boyega driver
never once so much a smirk upon being
hugged he'd stand awkwardly until boyega
was done before walking away game of
Lear's everyone has their favorite game
of Thrones characters but two characters
in particular of sparked fans
imaginations thanks to their hilariously
one-sided sexual tension bearded
wildling tormund Giantsbane played by
christopher hibiyo and a long-legged
sentinel of iron play to justice Brienne
of Tarth played by Gwendolyn
I wanted to make babies and uh incoming
great baby Moses conquered the world
Christy said that even she was taken
aback at the magnitude of intense sexual
intention if you brought the role
something he carried over between takes
he reportedly attempted to woo her by
centrally eating his sandwich while
maintaining unflinching eye contact in
full costume between takes which to be
fair sounds exactly like something
tormund would do for any kind of making
love to that sound where just he STI
which is a lot of whoa strong ice like
laces mrs. Doubtfire visited an adult
show mrs. Doubtfire is fondly remembered
as one of Robin Williams most famous
roles but before the film was announced
he decided to see just how well the
costume disguised his extremely famous
face by visiting an adult shop in San
Francisco Williams walked into the store
in full mrs. Doubtfire gear and started
browsing the various items on display
asking an increasingly bemused cashier
the most uncomfortable questions he
could think of in doubt fires wonderful
old lady voice and finally the guy
realized to his Mima get out of here
Robbie thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]